so spark toro is a social media data  analyzer and one of the things that  spark toro looked at uh the platform  sparktoro is the list of social media  accounts frequented by elon musk  followers and not shockingly it shows a  very  right wing bent jordan peterson  um  the guy who runs bar stool sports  republican congressman jim jordan  conspiracy theorist  jack  right winger stephen crowder trump's  former  press secretary kaylee mcinanni and  prison planet one of the offshoot i  guess shows of alex jones infowar so it  doesn't mean elon musk is right-wing  necessarily and elon musk has lots of  left-wing ideas on energy and other  things  but his followers are very heavily  sucked into the right-wing echo chamber  surprising let me know in the comments